In order to illustrate
correlated equilibrium and
why you would care about it,
I want to first introduce a game.
This is game theory after all and
this is the game of chicken.
Are you familiar with
the game of chicken?
>> I have seen the game of chicken
on movies from the 40s and
stuff or 50s or 60s.
The General Tso part doesn't make
sense to me, but the chicken part.
It's like cars rushing at each other and
teenage, I'm going to say boys,
deciding whether or not they're going to
be chickens and swerve off the road or
whether they're going to be,
tough guys and risk dying.
>> Right, that's exactly right.
So the two versions are two cars going
towards one another, vroom vroom vroom.
Voom voom voom.
And who's going to swerve first?
What happens if they swerve
in the same direction?
I've never even thought of.
The other one is where they're both
driving towards a cliff as fast as they
can and who's going to either dive out
of the car at the last minute were turn
their car away.
And the chicken is the one who loses
the girl because this is in the 1950s.
>> The girl's in the car
going over the cliff?
>> No, the girl's usually
the one that starts the race.
>> It's the 50's,
it was a different time Michael.
>> Understand.
>> And what does that have to do with
General Tso's, well I'm-
>> Or game theory, for that matter.
>> Well, it's a game right?
In fact, we can turn it into a game.
And how do we know it's a game?
Because I can draw a matrix.
So I'm going to say that
there are two actions here.
You can either chicken out.
>> Okay.
>> Or you can dare.
>> So let's just draw a matrix
that captures that idea.
So I'll just put it right here.
Okay.
So there's a matrix you can either
dare or you can be a chicken.
>> Okay, uh-huh.
>> Okay now, if both of you dare then
you both get zero because that's what
death is equal to in this world zero.
>> I see nothing good
ever happens again.
>> Right nothing good ever
happens again you just you dare.
So you both got the girl, but
you both died so it didn't really help.
>> You don't get
the girl if you're dead.
>> That's probably true.
Okay, so, on the other hand you
could there and the other guy could
chicken out in which case you get
seven and the chicken gets to why two?
Because you get to live another day he.
>> Live but
you get to live in constant shame.
>> That's exactly right
which is worth two.
>> Cool.
>> Apparently.
>> All right.
>> Or
of course the this is a symmetric game,
so
if I chicken out and
you dare it works the other way.
And the other option is
both chicken out and
that's a whole lot
better than being dead.
And it's actually better
than living in shame alone
because you're sharing the shame.
But it's not as good as having
dared while the other chickened.
Chickened out.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so that sounds good?
>> Yeah, 6 seems kind of high but
I can live with that.
>> Yeah it's math, Michael.
It doesn't really matter.
[LAUGH] So it's a general sum game and
it's a matrix and
all this other stuff about cars and
everything don't matter anymore
because everything is the matrix.